this question says vera's dinner plate
is divided into three equal sized
sections
fiera puts all her broccoli in one
section
and then we're asked what fraction of
vera's plate has broccoli
okay so we have a plate with three equal
sized sections
and we know that vera puts broccoli in
one section
and we're asked to figure out what
fraction of the plate that is
so we can draw virus plate try to
represent this with a picture
maybe viera's plate is a rectangle we
don't really know
but a rectangle will work
as long as it has three equal size
sections so let's try to draw that
this may not be perfect we could
probably do that second one a little
better
but this should represent
three equal size sections on a plate
and then we know she puts broccoli in
one of those sections so let's use green
draw some broccoli
broccoli broccoli broccoli
and
then look at this picture and ask
ourselves what fraction of virus plate
has broccoli
well our fraction is going to have a
numerator
on top
will be how many sections have broccoli
which is one
and then our denominator will be out of
the total number of equal sections and
we know there are three
equal sized sections so one third or one
of the three sections has broccoli